russia is expected to declare a
temporary ceasefire in and around two
ukrainian cities that have faced heavy
bombardment russian forces are set to
stop fighting to allow people in mario
pole and vol novaca a safe passage out
mario pole has been under siege for days
with residents facing a shortage of
electricity food and water
jonah hull has been covering
developments from la viv hello there
jonah what more are you hearing about
reports of a potential ceasefire in and
around mario pole to allow these
residents to leave
well good morning it is 700 gmt of
course 9 a.m here in ukraine 10 a.m
russian time and the very latest that we
are receiving uh first of all a report
from the russian ministry of defense
indicating that as of 100 hours 10 a.m
russia time moscow time that is a bigger
pardon russian forces will cease fire
around the towns of mariopol and
volnovaka that's a little bit inland
from mario paul but also in the south uh
to allow humanitarian corridors to open
up and
apparently confirming those reports uh
reports coming from inside mario paul
from the mayor vadim boychenko who's
been pretty vocal in the last few days
describing appalling conditions inside
the city he says
that a green corridor
is in the process of being opened the
occupiers guns
ceasing in what he's described as a
regime of silence
so that appears to be confirmation from
inside mario paul that as we speak
a humanitarian corridor is being opened
we don't know any more detail about that
we don't know how long
it will be opened we don't know how many
points of exit around the city that it
might
cover we don't know exactly what it will
allow to enter and exit the city
but mayor boychenko has been as i said
very descriptive in the last few days
talking about conditions inside mario
paul it's been
surrounded and besieged for several days
now cut off from water from electricity
from heat you can see the conditions
around me the temperature's
extremely low it's also running low on
food supplies and
medical supplies he's talked about
mass casualties in recent days they've
been unable to even remove the injured
in some places from the streets so this
humanitarian corridor
could not possibly be more necessary and
remember there are other places in
ukraine that need them two talks on
thursday between the two sides agreed
humanitarian corridors would be set up
this appears to be the first of them
okay jonah stay with us we want to cross
back to you in just a moment but let's
get an update now on the latest from
ukraine's president who's accusing nato
of giving russia the green light to
further bombard and kill ukrainians
vladimir zielinski says the alliance's
refusal to establish a no-fly zone will
only add to civilian deaths
the city of geneva at just 143
kilometers from the capital kiev came
under heavy bombardment overnight
the sheer scale of destruction is
getting worse as russian forces move
deeper into ukraine
president zielinski blamed any future
deaths or destruction on nato's inaction
all the people who die from this day
forward will die because of you because
of your weakness because of your lack of
unity all that the alliance was able to
do today was to pass through its
procurement system 50 tons of diesel
fuel for ukraine perhaps so that we
could burn the budapest memorandum
guaranteeing ukraine's security
so jonah certainly some fierce criticism
from the ukrainian president but that's
unlikely to be enough for nato to change
its mind
well vladimir zelinsky's message
absolutely is hardening now all the time
towards the west remember at the
beginning of this invasion it was his
address to eu leaders at the eu council
in brussels when he said this may be the
last time you see me that spurred them
into action in that massive package and
successive packages of sanctions aimed
at
the russian president and his inner
circle and now as you say this
extraordinary message to nato that the
blood will be on nato's hands if it
fails to apply a no-fly zone russian uh
ukrainian uh the ukrainian president and
his ministers repeatedly calling for a
no-fly zone now and calling it a failure
of nato a failure of nato's unity if it
doesn't do so well
you know the reality is this comes as
nato you know is congratulating itself
on its very unity in protecting its
eastern flank but that does not include
ukraine ukraine is not a member and jen
stoltenberg on friday was abundantly
clear about this when he was asked yet
again about a no-fly zone he said this
is not nato's war nato cannot prosecute
a no-fly zone that would mean shooting
russian planes down that could herald an
awful conflict between russia and the
west with potential nuclear implications
indeed thank you very much for bringing
us up to speed jonah live for us in la
viv